you
[Music]
Amami Oshima is an island off the coast
of mainland Japan and while it's well
known for its thriving coral reefs and
sandy beaches its sumo that puts this
island on the map Amami Oshima takes
great pride in raising young boys to
become some of the country's best
wrestlers ataxia Morita 0km Oh Samia
smoked Roberto identity ye sumo here
goes your mo canto post a masseuse
macoco de xalapa Guga depending synaptic
data in autumn with over 150 dokey O's
or sumo rings Amami Oshima has the
highest concentration of sumo facilities
in Japan making the sport accessible to
most young people on the island book on
my Rob Lee Scott how do these small
walks game us to take one cup to detail
into
[Music]
he's gone
underneath cake was dead dogs dead
serious Philip but sumo is not only
practiced as a means for future success
it's an on to the islands history and
has been embedded in its culture for
hundreds of years
[Music]
annual festivals include sumo
tournaments where wrestlers come out to
participate own inside you know very
much dear amiga meanies hagaru-ri
guitarist motor eaten raw
Karen oh it's a Jewish deli must know
their chief academic our our Kannamma
demo Minnetonka Theory gives this but
despite the islands efforts to maintain
sumo as a cultural staple the sport has
begun to decrease in popularity among
young people
they were kilometers ahead Tech students
at all well chief I should have been not
even are follow-through material type of
finish their mother need dental they get
cigarettes
modest terminologies and a demo on our
radar ni below
- a morning-after with me seven miles
off Estonia's west coast in Eastern
Europe lies the small island of canoe a
bucolic and serene place that feels lost
in time home to just 400 people it
functions like one of the world's few
matriarchal societies this is a place
where women roll
well mostly everything
[Music]
my name is Mariana tusks I lived almost
all my life in this island our lifestyle
is different comparing the lifestyle in
the mainland many old editions fill our
life
one such tradition is that canoes men
spend months away at sea fishing for the
island meanwhile canoes women are in
charge of leading the community and
preserving its way of life
men were always wrong time away from the
island and sometimes a historical reason
why women become a very strong very
independent kid no questions interesting
because we have killer additional
costumes because I everyday wearing she
is making skirts because she has five
granddaughters we have ancient folk
songs still alive and dances they have a
lot of practical skills how to live all
over the year here yes life is more
difficult here to survive it's pressure
for 1000 Islanders they all described
Island that it's like a paradise it's
the best place in the world we hadn't
made off camera era an image in her go
to form the ring gear I got rocked again
nice and employee says ki tamanna
machine near our laws of justice quicker
start up a leak on mostly the clothes
the music the dancing all of it has been
recognized by UNESCO on its intangible
cultural heritage list the keynote
rating songs and many traditions are
more than two thousand years old so this
is the main thing why we are in this
UNESCO List
the same list acknowledges canoes women
as the custodians of their islands
heritage I concern everybody that our
unique culture can disappear it's very
relevant if those things still exist and
they survived and the modern world it's
really miracl
a two hour boat ride of the coast of
Colombia is an island the most densely
populated island on earth
[Music]
santa cruz del is latte consists of more
than 1,200 people living on land the
size of two soccer fields making it four
times as dense as manhattan on the
island is a school that runs up to the
tenth grade two shops and one restaurant
there is no steady supply of water and a
Seoul generator that only runs for five
hours per day there are no police but
there isn't much need for them as
everyone on the island knows each other
a hundred and fifty years ago the island
was primarily uninhabited and was
sometimes used by local fishermen as a
place to rest and take shelter during
storms gradually some fishermen came to
build their homes here these were the
grandparents and great-grandparents of
the current generation of residents
despite the close living quarters
inhabitants on the island say they
wouldn't give up their peaceful
existence for anything not even a little
more room
[Music]
Oh Kenosha Irma Island is a short 12
minute ferry ride from her Ocean region
of Japan while the sandy and palm-lined
beaches are perfect for holidaymakers
the island draws crowds for a different
reason
rabbits lots of oh and how they got
there is a mystery between 1929 1945 the
Japanese army secretly produced over
6,000 tons of poison gas on Okinawa
Island
some believe the current rabbits are
descendants of those brought to the
island to test the gas but the current
director of the poison gas museum
insists these bunnies have nothing to do
with those from the world war ii era so
where did they come from
you know saggy kimono saggy you don't
necessary have on this you know more
one theory a cocoon in science
redecoratin wah Thank You Nana zucchini
today khadijah so for the Catena Saki
naka de uno momento de artes money mata
mata colinearity massa
so those rabbits were released and with
no real predators they bred like well
like rabbits and yet another theory
no Mario Kunichika y estoy foto de I
know can coordinate Doheny who's a
youkai hajimeta
sorry da Amano Okinawa day talk some
creatively they can coca call your
karate master so you don't go very
nicely
either way this new generation of feral
rabbits has a run of the land they're
creating a new story separate from the
sordid past of Okinawa Island an island
once known for death is now known for
possibly the cutest thing ever
bunnies
[Music]
what do you say to people who just say
this is not a normal way of thank you
very much
[Music]
I'm Katherine and this is my husband
Wayne I'm Wayne and welcome to freedom
code
[Music]
we live in a secluded Cove the only
options we have to get here is by water
there are no road accesses the water is
our highway everything that you see here
in our home is floating we are tied to
shore with lines we are not anchored we
have our main living house we have the
dance floor
the lighthouse building for green houses
as I started to grow the garden and make
it larger than we had to have more space
for that garden everybody's done with a
handsaw on hammering no power tools I
know every board and nail by name it's
about 500 tons a million pounds and I'm
flowing I've been building tree fort
since I was seven and I said well dad
I'm putting the tree fort in the ocean
no when I go uptown again Lansing mm-hmm
the thing about living in clack would
sound on the west coast of Vancouver
Island it's the richest biomass owner so
the opportunity to fish for dinner is it
I just get in my canoe and paddle out in
ten minutes I can catch a fish but when
it's windy into too rough out there I'll
land the coach or fish out of the house
I was hoping to make a lot more money as
an artist so subsistence living was our
only opportunity to have anything as
artists we could never buy real estate
so we had to make our own it was a great
opportunity to actually move away from
the city to see if we could prosper out
here now 24 years later we're still
doing it
I can't imagine living any other way I
feel completely fulfilled oh that's good
huh nice
[Music]